[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 dans les Yvelines
14 communes ont été sélectionnées pour
tester le dépôt de plainte par
visio-conférence pourquoi proposer ce
dispositif dans quelles conditions et
situation peut-on porter plainte en
visioconférence pour en parler avec nous
je suis aujourd'hui avec Alexis Morin
vous êtes au commissaire de police et
chef de la Sûreté urbaine dans la
circonscription de la sécurité publique
d'Élancourt bonjour bonjour alors depuis
le 9 mai 2023 les citoyens de 14
communes des Yvelines peuvent déposer
plainte en visio-conférence c'est
d'ailleurs une première en France
pourquoi ce dispositif a-t-il été mis en
place et à quel besoin répond-il
alors effectivement ça a été mis en
place le 9 mai donc de cette année donc
c'est la possibilité pour les victimes
de déposer plainte par visioconférence
effectivement c'est dans 14 communes
donc les 9 communes de la
circonscription de sécurité d'Élancourt
et les cinq communes qui sont rattachées
à la brigade de gendarmerie de
Magny-les-Hameaux et en fait ce besoin
il s'inscrit si vous voulez dans la
numérisation des services publics que ce
soit tous les services publics autres
que la police mais aussi la police et
cette volonté de permettre si vous
voulez aux citoyens de pouvoir faire de
plus en plus de démarches en ligne donc
effectivement il pouvait déjà les
citoyens par exemple déclarer leurs
impôts en ligne prendre des rendez-vous
médicaux en ligne et aujourd'hui ils
peuvent aussi pour les personnes
concernées déposer plainte en ligne et
en visio en visioconférence du coup
parce que alors on a on a déjà le dépôt
de plein temps en ligne qui est qui est
possible enfin en tout cas prendre
rendez-vous pour pour se rendre dans un
commissaire de police là c'est un petit
peu différent donc c'est vraiment le
dépôt de plainte en visioconférence
qu'est-ce que ça apporte alors
effectivement c'est différent de la pré
plainte en ligne là c'est vraiment un
dispositif complet ou la personne en
fait va être mis en lien avec un
policier pour déposer plainte donc à
travers un système de visioconférence et
recevra ensuite sa plainte par mail on
le verra ou elle devra signer mais
peut-être que je préciserai plus tard
les différents les différents types de
plaintes qui peut qui peut y avoir en
tout cas ça permet à la différence des
préprints en ligne de passer par le
portail ma sécurité et passer par
Internet pour être en face d'un policier
et pouvoir lui expliquer donc les
problèmes que le clavier qui m'a eu
l'infraction à laquelle a subi et pour
entamer une discussion via
visioconférence menant à une plainte
prise donc 100% en ligne parmi les
communes celle de Coignières Guyancourt
manileamo Élancourt ou encore
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et châteaux forts
commencent ces communes ont été
sélectionnés pour prendre par vos tests
et pourquoi des communes du département
des Yvelines alors là-dessus si vous
voulez je vais pas pouvoir vous donner
une une réponse très précise je pense
que c'est parce que ce bassin de
population représente finalement assez
bien la population française on peut
avoir des quartiers un petit peu
sensibles peut-être des quartiers plus
aisés et on a aussi tout type
d'infraction donc voilà tout ce qui est
vol de véhicule vol de portable violence
intrafamiliale dégradation viol donc je
pense que c'est un voilà un bassin de
population qui représente bien la
population et qui permet un petit peu de
faire un test on va dire grandeur nature
de l'expérimentation visio plainte à
l'heure où nous enregistrons cette cette
émission le dispositif était effectif
depuis seulement quelques semaines
est-ce qu'il est déjà possible de faire
un premier bilan sur l'affluence des des
plaintes en visioconférence c'est ce
qu'il y a sans donner le chiffre exact à
peu près combien de plaintes ont déjà
été déposés en visioconférence non c'est
c'est trop tôt pour faire un bilan je
vous avoue on a on a quand même
communiqué avec les partenaires donc
notamment les mairies qu'on fait
beaucoup de travail pour pour promouvoir
aussi le l'expérimentation à côté de ça
on a pour l'instant eu 5 6 plaintes en
visio et malheureusement c'est trop tôt
pour vous faire un retour par contre les
personnes qui sont interrogées donc
doivent répondre à chaque fois à un
questionnaire de satisfaction et ils ont
fait part donc les victimes qui ont
déposé plainte par visio ils ont fait
part quand même de leur satisfaction
quand tu as le voilà la modernisation de
de la police nationale et de la
gendarmerie pour le dépôt de plainte on
va justement revenir sur sur ces
plaintes quelles sont les étapes pour
pouvoir déposer une plainte en
visioconférence ou est-ce qu'on doit se
rendre alors
c'est assez simple et assez assez
intuitif donc si vous voulez il faut
vous rendre donc sur le portail ma
sécurité c'est le portail alors c'est
soit sur le site soit une application
le portail si vous voulez unique de pour
rentrer en lien avec les forces de
sécurité intérieure autre bien sûr
l'appel 17 qui reste a priorisé en cas
d'urgence je me permets de le rappeler
mais donc il faut se rendre sur ce
portail ma sécurité et ensuite en fait
on a un orienteur qui va nous poser de
trois questions donc la première c'est
je suis victime ensuite quel type
d'infraction est-ce que je connais
l'auteur et on va ensuite arriver sur
sur un petit voilà un petit encart en
disant si je suis dans une de ces
communes des Yvelines donc les 14 je
teste l'expérimentation Viso plainte et
ensuite donc on va cliquer sur
l'excellentation et on va être mis sur
un agenda avec différents créneaux
horaires qui vont être proposés pour en
fait une prise de rendez-vous donc la
personne va choisir un créneau horaire
en fonction de ses disponibilités et va
recevoir un sms et un mail de
confirmation du rendez-vous après le
jour l'heure du rendez-vous donc la
personne recevra un lien sur lequel
devra cliquer pour se connecter elle
cliquera sur le lien elle sera mise dans
un salon d'attente et il y aura si vous
voulez un enquêteur qui va de son côté
recevoir une notification comme quoi la
personne est en attente elle va cliquer
sur le début de la vidéo conférence et
les deux personnes vont être mises donc
en lien via le les webcam et le dépôt de
plainte du coup débute débute à ce
moment-là deux plages horaires sont pour
le moment effectif de 9h à midi et de
14h à 17h lors d'un dépôt de plein de
basique vous vous assurez notamment de
la bonne identité de la personne comment
comment ça se passe lors d'un dépôt de
plates en visioconférence alors juste
pour préciser effectivement le les
créneaux horaire la première semaine
c'était 9h midi 14h 17h on essaie un
petit peu de proposer des créneaux rares
plus larges pour que les personnes
puissent prendre rendez-vous quand elles
le souhaitent donc depuis cette semaine
il y a les créneaux entre midi et deux
qui sont aussi ouverts et très
prochainement aussi des horaires de
weekend donc là ça demande une petite
organisation opérationnelle mais c'est
ce qui est prévu en tout cas sachant que
les collègues de la gendarmerie
proposent aussi des créneaux peut-être
un peu plus tard le soir et déjà le
week-end alors vous nous avez parlé
justement que le territoire en tout cas
les 14 communes sélectionnées
représentent un panel un échantillon
finalement qu'on peut retrouver dans la
France entière quel genre de plainte on
peut déposer en vision conférence et ce
qu'on peut déposer tout genre de plainte
alors au stade de l'expérimentation il y
a pas de limite quant aux infractions
c'est à dire que on peut déposer plainte
pour tout type d'infraction donc que ce
soit des dégradations légères ou des
violences aggravées
après effectivement il peut y avoir dans
certains cas pour des infractions assez
graves
la nécessité de se rendre au
commissariat alors soit parce que ça a
mené à une enquête et qu'il y aura des
actes plus tard dans quête qui
nécessiteront la présence de la personne
ou soit parce que finalement
l'infraction est trop complexe pour être
prise en visioconférence là ça ça
dépendra beaucoup de la l'enquêteur de
du policier qui recueille la plainte qui
peut-être pourra dire là c'est c'est
compliqué ça nécessite beaucoup de
détails beaucoup de temps je préfère que
vous veniez au commissariat on prend
rendez-vous mais on vous recevra
peut-être dans des meilleures conditions
pour que vous puissiez expliquer votre
votre l'infraction vous avez subi
toujours avec cette idée que en cas
d'urgence il faut de toute façon faire
le faire le numéro de la police et ne
pas passer justement par cette majorette
alors la peur de certains citoyens c'est
peut-être cette angoisse de passer par
Internet et donc d'être peut-être exposé
ou enregistré pendant un dépôt de
plainte est-ce que les conditions
restent les mêmes est-ce que vous
assurez la sécurité du plaignant ou de
la plaignante alors oui les la sécurité
du plaignant ou de la cliente est bien
entendu bien entendu assuré
au contraire ça peut permettre
aux plaignant de pouvoir s'assurer
peut-être de plus de confidentialité je
m'explique je m'explique pour certains
cas il peut y avoir des personnes des
victimes qui refusent d'aller au
commissariat parce que aller au
commissariat ça peut être un petit peu
stressant c'est pas anodin et à côté de
ça si elles y vont pour dénoncer
d'autres personnes
il peut elle peut être connue par
exemple par des personnes autour du
commissariat donc si vous voulez viser
plainte ça permet aussi un peu de
confidentialité parce que la personne
peut finalement choisir quand elle
dépose plainte et choisir le lieu où
elle dépose plainte donc ou soit un lieu
sécurisé bien sûr où elle est en
sécurité donc à domicile je sais pas
dans la voiture au travail dans une
salle un petit peu isolée et si vous
voulez ça ça permet peut-être de toucher
des personnes qui n'osaient pas franchir
la porte du commissariat et qui vont
grâce à avoir quand même accès à au
service public de de sécurité mais c'est
aussi un bon un bon moyen pour les
personnes vivant en zone rurale
peut-être avec quels sont un peu plus
éloignées aussi de de tout ça alors oui
bien sûr en zone rurale et même plus
largement aux personnes qui ont des
emplois du temps qui sont assez chargés
si vous voulez l'avantage numéro un
c'est quand même cette possibilité de de
gérer son temps en fait parce que même
si même si on fait tout si vous voulez
pour que le temps de d'attente à
l'accueil soit soit le plus restreint
possible des fois il y a beaucoup
d'influences donc beaucoup d'attentes
pour déposer plaintes et là ça permet
vraiment aux personnes de choisir le
moment et nous on assure de notre côté
que le jour et l'heure du rendez-vous